e aí
é quem decide o que será curado e o que
será celebrado na nossa sociedade
é quem decide o que é perfeito e o que é
normal eo que é errado o que é anormal o
que não será aceito
o que regra é essa que nos rege e quem
inventou a regra você já se perguntaram
sobre isso
e provavelmente não eu demorei tempo
demais para mim perguntar
olá eu sou escritora e ativista e
profissional da inclusão mas aquilo que
eu mais mergulhar dizer que eu sou a mãe
do joão e eu nunca quis ser mãe é sempre
achei esse lugar endeusado das mães e
distante demais de mim informações
recentes dizem que a maternidade é a
professora nata da soft skills que serão
as mais requisitadas do futuro do
trabalho são habilidades sócio afetivas
comunicação empatia adaptabilidade
coragem isso me fez pensar no outro
conceito está sendo muito usado hoje
também que é o life long learning que
disse que o nosso aprendizado é continue
e não precisa necessariamente de um
ambiente formal de educação ele acontece
das nossas vivências nas nossas
experiências a vida como uma sala de
aula eu fui daquelas grávidas apavorados
que correu para curso de maternidade de
primeira viagem e eu comprei todos
aqueles livros
o check-list de regras para gente
controlar o desenvolvimento de um bebê
eu não recomendo o joão nasceu como um
menino típico alegre doce destemido ele
sentou rolou falou correu ele foi
descobrindo o mundo exatamente como eu
esperava que acontecesse exatamente como
os livros tinham me dito que seria o
correto com 1 ano e 8 meses ele sofreu a
primeira crise de sua uma doença rara e
auto-imune que a gente descobriu no 71
dias que ele ficou internado desses dias
45 joão tava em coma por causa de um avc
muito grave que ele sofreu
e nos piores momentos que são aqueles
dias que os médicos vem na porta e dizem
mais 48 horas talvez eu não me despedir
eu nunca soube rezar mas eu implorava
para deuses e deusas e qualquer coisa
que existe nesse universo para que me
permitissem que o aprendizado que era
meu destinado para mim pudesse acontecer
com joão do meu lado e não a partir da
perda dele como eu não tinha certeza se
os deuses estavam me ouvindo eu apelei
para chantagem emocional também eu
afastava os fios que mantinham o meu
filho vivo e falava no ouvido dele tá
liberado o doce durante a semana
e eu prometi também as férias dos sonhos
negocia e noites e noites de cama
compartilhada e até o horário de dormir
tudo para que ele ficasse e ele ficou o
meu menino doce destemido alegre como
sempre foi usando uma cadeira de rodas e
algumas outras adaptações que aumentaram
muitas possibilidades dele um bilhão de
pessoas no mundo tem algum tipo de
deficiência e vocês não sabem disso 24
por cento da população brasileira se
autodeclara pessoa com deficiência e
vocês não sabem disso o preconceito
contra pessoa com deficiência têm nome é
capacitismo e você também não devem
saber disso vocês são capacetes em
potencial e eu sei disso porque ontem eu
também era
e eu vi 25 anos da minha vida sem nenhum
laço afetivo com uma pessoa com
deficiência eu não tive um amigo nenhum
colega nenhum parente nenhum amor 25
anos sem convivência nenhuma com um
quarto da população brasileira
e a verdade é que nós somos educados
para ter medo do diferente porque a
gente vive numa estrutura que não acolhe
a diferença ela exclui a diferença e
numa sociedade que continua fingindo que
as pessoas não existem mas as pessoas
existem a gente tem indícios desde a
pré-história que o homem já com vivia
com a deficiência e aí ao longo dos
arcos às pessoas com deficiência se
envolveram e narrativas de abandono de
rejeição várias narrativas diferentes
primeiro por não ter o mesmo ritmo
enquanto a gente era um povo nômade
depois por não ser não ter o corpo
perfeito belo e forte que os gregos
conceituaram ea em algum momento as
pessoas com deficiência passam a ser
vista como aberrações castigos de deus e
depois rotulados como doentes e tratadas
assim como até hoje ainda acontece aí
vieram as guerras e um aumento
considerável do número de pessoas com
deficiência por violência e
o industrial que botou o valor do homem
no quanto ele consegue produzir em menos
tempo uma competição desleal que vai dar
de novo para pessoa com deficiência o
olhar de inválida de não pertencente
pessoas típicas sempre decidirão o
destino de pessoas com deficiência ao
longo do tempo nos estados unidos há um
tempo atrás a pessoa com deficiência não
podia estar no ambiente público se eu
tivesse um restaurante ficasse
incomodada pela presença de uma eu podia
chamar a polícia ela ser retirada na
segunda guerra mundial hitler autorizou
um programa de eutanásia e decretou que
a pessoa com deficiência tinha uma vida
indigna de ser vivida 300 mil pessoas
entre adultos e crianças foram mortos
mas absolutamente ninguém fala sobre
isso
a rejeição e abandono e essas são
histórias assustadoramente recentes até
pouquíssimo tempo atrás o meu filho não
tinha nem direito de uma escola regular
e por isso ainda hoje mesmo sendo lei
muitas se sentem confortáveis de
continuar negando esse acesso para ele
e o capacitismo essa ideia torta de que
pessoas com deficiência são inferiores
às pessoas têm deficiência são pessoas
vistas como anormais ser humanos que
precisam ser corrigidos de alguma forma
ser humanos que precisam de conserto
e são vistos dessa forma coletivamente
com essas condições naturais com essas
condições de nascença como algo que
precisa de conserto e o meu filho ele
não precisa ser consertado esse
preconceito tem várias faces como todos
os outros a gente tem a versão do
coitadinho capaz que vocês devem já
conhecer e coloca a pessoa com
deficiência no lugar quase sub-humano e
que vai subir este mas capacidade dessa
pessoa tem nem deixar ela se apresentar
a gente tem vários tipos e níveis de
deficiência gestão tá falando de uma
categoria tá falando de pessoas tá
falando do joão da alice do hotel da
gabi pessoas com histórias e potências
muito diferentes a gente também tem a
visão do doente que é muito perigosa
porque deixou subentendido necessidade
de uma cura a necessidade da reversão de
um problema
e a deficiência não é uma doença é uma
condição e sim uma pessoa com
deficiência pode perfeitamente ter uma
vida saudável por fim a gente vai ter as
narrativas do herói da superação muitas
vezes usadas para contar as nossas
histórias que vão nos desumanizar tanto
quanto as primeiras mas essa parece um
elogio a sociedade que impõe uma série
de obstáculos na vida de uma pessoa com
deficiência ou não faz questão nenhuma
de retirá-los é a mesma que vai dar uma
medalha para o sujeito que consegui com
muito esforço e sofrimento passar por
algumas dessas barreiras olhando para
essa pessoa como um objeto de inspiração
romantizando a exclusão e deixa no lugar
de conformidade a ideia de que o mundo
não é para pessoa com deficiência
bom então vocês não consertam as
calçadas de vocês mas quando um
cadeirante empinar sua cadeira e de uma
forma muito surpreendente conseguir
transpor uma calçada que mais parece um
rali vocês vão gravar um vídeo colocar
nas redes e dizer os verdadeiros heróis
do brasil eu troco fácil a medalha de
super-herói de supermãe de superação por
uma vida mais digna que não me leve até
o limite eu troco fácil pela
possibilidade do joão tem o direito de
ser apenas uma menina que ele é
crescendo como qualquer um outro
e a gente precisa urgentemente mudar o
ponto de vista entender que os lugares
são deficientes as ideias são
deficientes as nossas formas de ensino a
moda o design as soluções que a gente
insiste em fazer mesmo que a gente saiba
que não estão atendendo todas as pessoas
porque isso a gente pode mudar é
capacitismo quando você vai ajudar uma
pessoa com deficiência na rua sem
perguntar se ela precisa de ajuda eu já
ouvi muitas histórias de pessoas com
deficiência visual que estavam paradas
na esquina esperando um amigo um
namorado pegando um ar e de repente uma
pessoa pega no braço dela e atravessa
lojas de ruas sem dar nenhuma explicação
se é sequestro gente
e é capacitismo quando a gente só fala
com a pessoa que está acompanhando a
pessoa com deficiência mesmo quando a
gente tá falando sobre ela como se ela
não tivesse ali quando uma pessoa me faz
uma pergunta sobre o joão e ele está
presente normalmente eu respondo com uma
pergunta também porque você não pergunta
para ele
e é capacitismo quando a gente
infantilismo nosso tom de voz para falar
com uma pessoa com deficiência que
muitas vezes é um jovem ou um adulto ou
quando a gente encosta no corpo dessa
pessoa sem pedir autorização é
capacitismo quando a gente olha para uma
pessoa com deficiência e fica grato pela
nossa vida normal e quando a gente usa
palavras como surdo cego para
se referir a pessoas típicas na intenção
de ofender ou de brincar não importa é
capacitismo quando você disse que você
só quer que o seu filho nasça perfeito
excluindo a existência de um bilhão de
pessoas no mundo e quando você diz e
afirma que uma criança típica um
profissional com deficiência vai
atrapalhar prejudicar o funcionamento de
uma turma ou de uma equipe de trabalho
e é capacitismo quando uma pessoa chegar
para mim e dizer mas o seu filho é tão
bonitinho começou uma pessoa com
deficiência não pudesse ser bonita ou
quando me pergunta assim ele entende
alguma coisa partindo da crença que uma
pessoa numa cadeira de rodas não deve
entender nada é capacitismo quando você
fica irritado na fila de um banco
supermercado ou no ônibus por uma pessoa
com deficiência tá atrasando o seu dia a
sua vida tem nunca se perguntar se ela
não tá atrasada para vida dela e o
despreparo dos profissionais desse
estabelecimento ou alguém que estacionar
numa vaga prioritária indevidamente não
atrasou ainda mais porque você nem
cogita que essa pessoa tem uma vida para
se atrasar
e o que vocês querem desejam para as
crianças que vocês amam lá no futuro
eu tenho amigos amores vitórias portas
abertas por merecimento eu também desejo
isso para joão mas esse merecimento
precisa vir a partir de contextos
inclusivos que permitam que isso
aconteça
e dizem que empatia é se colocar na pele
do outro só que isso é impossível a
gente se acostumou a fazer aquela
perguntinha e se fosse comigo só que ela
não tem como dar certo porque depois
dela a única coisa que a gente vai
encontrar a gente mesmo como eu me
sentiria se tivesse no lugar do outro
mas eu não tô no lugar do outro e a
verdadeira empatia começa quando a gente
assumi isso quando a gente entende que a
gente não sabe nada sobre essa outra
pessoa e a gente se permite escutar o
que ela tem para nos dizer o maior
conhecimento sobre a inclusão vem das
pessoas que vivem a falta dela o
protagonismo dessa fala é e precisa ser
da pessoa com deficiência da família da
típicas muitas vezes representadas por
uma mãe que ainda vai ser na maioria das
vezes solo
olá eu sou uma mulher se isso branca
hetero que a pessoa muitas coisas na
vida porque essas características exatas
portanto muito privilegiada no país como
nós desigual e intolerante e violento e
exclui pessoas todos os dias apenas por
serem quem são a maternidade atípica me
ensinou que privilégios são
responsabilidades e que enfrentar os
nossos preconceitos não é sobre combater
pessoas é sobre combater as ideias que
nos trouxeram até aqui não é sobre o
outro isso é diferente de mim é sobre
sermos diferentes um do outro existem
muitas formas de estar vivo e muitos
corpos possíveis mas quem realmente
pertence nas narrativas de vocês de
futuro quem pertence um abraço de vocês
no time de vocês nos lugares que vocês
ocupam com quem e para quem vocês criam
e quem é que tá faltando
e não tem nada de errado com meu filho o
que tá errado e precisa ser combatido é
o capacitismo é a falta de preparo de
acesso é a falta de vontade nada é mais
urgente e inovador do que incluir
pessoas do que encontrar o filtro ea
lente do afeto como último desdobramento
possível desse desconforto que a
consciência nos traz que seja então
é sobre curar preconceitos e celebrar
existências que seja sobre tentativas
comprometidas de verdade com a mudança
porque inclusão não é um favor
e o futuro é humano e diverso ou não
será a gente tá esperando por vocês
vocês vem obrigada tá
e aí